hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man far
from home has an amazing trailer that
gives us our first official look at the
sequel to spider-man homecoming and our
first look at Marvel phase 4 which will
apparently move on from the tragic end
of infinity war the same way we move on
from anything depressing by pretending
it never happened
mr. stark I feel terrific whoo yeah
somehow Marvel and Sony pulled off a far
from home trailer that doesn't overtly
spoil anything for Avengers end game
blood features just enough little Easter
eggs and cryptic clues to keep us
guessing it's marinating
but I got you covered with the
frame-by-frame breakdown of everything
you might have missed including some
extra footage from the International
trailer and of course spoiler warning
against any of my predictions end up
being too right they ruin your life
let's get started happy nice thank you
you too thank you new dress
yes it is what just happened okay this
opening clip takes place at a charity
benefit at the Salvation Army to aid the
homeless this could be a nod to
spider-man's volunteer work with beasts
in this spider-man ps4 game and may
Marissa Tomei now knows of course that
Peter is spider-man she did see him in
his suit in the final shot of homecoming
now the directors of Avengers infinity
were an endgame the Russo brothers
revealed that Aunt May did survive the
snap but Peter Parker definitely did not
so let us address this elephant-sized s
pile in the room how the hell is Peter
Parker alive again many are suggesting
that the events of this movie must be a
prequel in that Peters euro trip must
take place before infinity war like that
school bus that we see him on could have
been returning from the airport but far
from home definitely is not a prequel an
infinity war shortly after that scene
Peter told Tony Stark that he was
actually on his way to a field trip and
Marvel head Kevin Feige said far from
home would be about moving forward after
infinity war and after endgame and Sony
head Amy Pascal said separately that far
from home would start a few minutes
after in-game ends and while movie
directors and movie execs have made coy
and cryptic statements in the past like
I just don't think they would outright
lie about this rather I just think the
fact that Peter Parker is alive again is
however the Avengers will end up fixing
things in endgame on this channel we've
explored a number of theories traveling
through time to destroy each of the
Infinity stones before Thanos could get
his hands on them or maybe splitting
into an alternate reality or ultra
timeline where certain characters
survived the amazing movie spider-man
into the spider-verse introduced us to
the concept of the multiverse and how
while spider-man might die in one
dimension he can certainly live on and
grow older and fatter in another and
maybe that's what we're seeing here
maybe that's why no one is referencing
Thanos or the snap because it didn't
happen to these people this spider-man
could just be far from the home we're
familiar with ah I see what they did
there now there are a few other fun
Easter eggs in this section the framing
of spider-man facing the reporters in
the fans seems to reflect the famous
panel from the Civil War comics when
Peter Parker removes his mask and
reveals his identity to the
press-conference also look closely at
the lower left you can see a little girl
wearing a homemade paper plate
spider-man mask don't make fun you got
to be crafty with your cosplay when
you're homeless I'm wondering if this
could actually be a nod to that moment
an Iron Man 2
remember when Starks saved the little
boy who was wearing the Iron Man mask
that boy Kevin Feige later retconned as
a young Peter Parker I guess that
supposed to be Tom Holland under there
so maybe this girl Spidey fan could grow
up to be Gwen Stacy in the MCU though I
guess that would require Peter to become
the lizard we'll see also if you look
closely you can see the big check that
happy Hogan brings in for $500,000 it's
from the stark relief foundation and
it's signed by Pepper Potts CEO of
course of Stark Industries now happy
flirts with Aunt May kind of like how
Tony has done the past we do know that
happy also survived the snap so who
knows maybe back over in the darkest
timeline post snap over there these two
grieving survivors who each lost loved
ones consoled each other and hit it off
and maybe that's why they have this kind
of flirty metaphysical chemistry I love
talking timelines
let's move on
trip go to Europe school trip
let's get your passport Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please okay
as Peter packs for the trip he visits
Delmar's deli in Queens now we saw that
get destroyed at homecoming but check
out those newspaper front pages behind
the counter top Queens bodega destroyed
a blast
top bodega nice also some pictures with
Delmar with spider-man and what looks
like Barack Obama so it sounds like the
bodega has been repaired it have you
look at the lower edge of the frame
murder the cat is okay too next we see
Peter texting while swinging not safe I
love that we blitzed his phone to his
other hand when he change his hands to
swing look closely behind him two
important details here one notice at the
top of Grand Central Station has a new
statue to honor the cops firefighters
and relief workers from the Battle of
New York but that's not the only way
this version of Manhattan is recovering
lucky there's a new building being
constructed behind Grand Central that
could be the old Avengers Tower it's
actually based on the spot that the
real-life MetLife building is located in
the city right adjacent the Grand
Central Station of course the spider-man
homecoming Stark and Hogan were in the
process of moving everything out of that
Tower and now it appears that a new
owner is taking over the location one
theory is that this could be Oscorp
potentially introducing Norman Osborn
and Green Goblin to the MCU though in
that case that wouldn't mean that Oscorp
building couldn't appear in any other
non spider-man Marvel movies since
Osborn and all those Spidey villains are
still owned by Sony Marvel would have to
get special permission from Sony to just
feature a shot of it but another option
for this new building it could be the
Baxter building
that's the headquarters of the Fantastic
Four now of course the Fantastic Four
were previously a Marvel property owned
by Fox and now with this merger with
Disney some Fox Marvel crossovers could
start happening in phase four though I
think this would still just be too early
considering this whole deal probably
won't be finalized until March we also
see Peter picking up his passport from
the post office look closely Peter's
birthday is listed in August the same
month that amazing fantasy number 15 was
released that was spider-man's first
comic book appearance and also notice
how there are no years printed on the
passport nothing for Peters Berthier
nothing for the issue date now this does
make sense all passports have to have
years printed on them but I think this
exclusion is a deliberate move like
perhaps the events of Avengers endgame
will affect the timeline to influence
what you're far from home takes place in
and the
far from home wanted to avoid revealing
too much in this trailer and maybe the
theatrical version of this shot will
show us the year but also you gotta
remember spider-man homecoming was the
movie with that huge dumb eight years
later title card mess that directly
contradicted the main MCU timeline and
Confused the hell out of us nerds so it
seems like part of our moments learn the
lesson that when it comes to timeline
details less is more
on to the next clip have your suit I
just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need a
friendly neighborhood spider
here we see Peter packing and his
bedroom deciding to leave his spider-man
suit at home he just wants to enjoy his
vacation but as we see in the
international trailer and may actually
packs it anyway along with some spare
web fluid and his web-shooters
leading to this hilarious scared customs
these know you open air great also
looking closely at Peters bedroom here
you can see that he's a Mets fan with
them Mike Piazza pennant and a Star Wars
imperial star destroyer tour on the
shelf just like he had all the Star Wars
toys in the first movie Andy's wearing
another nerdy shirt an old geometry joke
with a problem find X and then the
arrows circle I found it but check out
his luggage there's a big Easter Egg
here BFP this is uncle ben's suitcase
Benjamin F Parker probably for Benjamin
Franklin Parker now he doesn't have an
official middle name in the comics but
his character was modeled on American
founding father Ben Franklin with all of
his wise adages until now Uncle Ben has
not been officially referenced in the
MCU since the Tom Hollands spider-man
wasn't an origin story apparently
director didn't want to make a reference
to Uncle Ben and Home Coming remember
that scene where Peter tries on
different suits for the dance and one of
them I guess was gonna belong to Ben but
the scene was cut now we see some shots
of Peter departing the International
trailer included more travel shots with
MJ going through security - along with
Ned who is now attached at the hip with
Betty Brant I guess they're together now
yes Betty of course there's a host of
that derpy school news show and in the
comics Betty actually goes on to work at
the Daily Bugle for Jay jonah Jameson
might remember Elizabeth Banks played
Betty in the Sam Raimi spider-man movies
and in the comics Betty also marries Ned
Leeds but she has a brief affair with
Flash Thompson when ned becomes
Hobgoblin
yeah just keep your eye on that one Ned
and before I move on we see the students
in Venice Italy and as Betty takes a
photo of men make up that boat in the
background a SM - one - that's probably
a nod to the amazing spider-man issue
212 that was the issue that introduces
the villain Hydra man who might show up
later in this trailer so let's move on
you look really pretty
therefore I have value no it's nice yeah
you look pretty - I just wanna spend
some time with him Jane I think
like to be my first time I love I had
just finished my from coffee in this
section Peter flirts with MJ in a movie
theater and students check into their
Venice hotel where you can see Martin
star returning this mr. Harrington and
JB smooth character another chaperone or
guide it looks like now they're out all
this we've been hearing the music of The
Ramones I want to be sedated and if you
listen closely the editing works in a
really fun joke here Ned and Peter enter
their room and the Ramones repeats the I
want to be sedated chorus but the word
sedated gets cut off right as Nick Fury
fires his dart at Ned in the neck
sedating him just finished my some
coffee god I love the wordplay there
let's move on so nice to finally meet
you spider-man
you're Nick Fury what some clothes on
let's go for a ride is he gonna be ok
like that might want to turn him over so
he doesn't swallow his tongue glad Nick
Fury remember to use the tranq gun and
not his other one who sits alone in the
dark in a hotel room of a couple
teenagers the former shield director of
your nightmares that's who but you know
we shouldn't be too hard on fury for
this it's kind of be hard for a guy like
him to trust people someone I lost you
know hey I got it in there now this
really is probably the first time Peter
Parker and Nick Fury of met fury did not
appear in civil war or in homecoming and
he and Peter never really crossed paths
in infinity war perhaps they will meet
an Avengers endgame though again we're
probably looking at some timeline
resetting or reality swapping so these
would be versions of Peter and fury who
never met and for those wondering why
Peter spidey sense didn't alert him to
the danger technically Peter wasn't in
danger here meg was so sorry Ned your
safety isn't within Peters spidey sense
jurisdiction moving on Nick Fury just
hijacked our summer vacation
get gifts Parker a job to do
are you going to step up or not okay
this trailer kicks him to spy mode as
fury takes spider-man to some base in
Venice probably to debrief him on a
mission and maybe hook him up with some
new gear now whatever happens in
Avengers endgame fury has now taken over
this role from Tony Stark and Tony's
absence doesn't necessarily mean he's
dead like it could just mean the studio
considers Spider Man a big enough MCU
hero to tentpole a movie without Ironman
this time and more likely they just
don't want to fork out the millions to
Robert Downey jr. to co-star we see fury
looking out a window and this is
actually the shard
it's a skyscraper in central London on
the south bank of the Thames theory is
looking out over whatever drama is going
down to the nearby Tower Bridge you can
actually see the shard in the background
of the reverse shot when Peter swoops in
and notice that Peter stone has changed
here it's more red and black making me
think that this is an upgraded suit
given to him by fury uses the web
gliders again from the original Steve
Ditko design of spider-man use these in
the Washington Monument sequence at
homecoming we also see fury and Maria
Hill shooting at this thing which looks
a lot like the spider-man villain
Sandman you might remember a version of
him from Raimi spider-man 3 but before
we go too deep into Sandman I'm not sure
this is Sandman I'm gonna go into an
alternate theory after we look at the
next section
your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
okay there's a lot to talk about here
first we see what appears to be even
more villains firing monster that breaks
out of this molten cocoon and this could
be the spider-man villain molten man we
also see a water-based villain that
could be hydro man which would tie in
with that hydro man Easter Egg that we
saw earlier but isn't it interesting
that we're seeing so many villains we
haven't even gotten to the main villain
of this movie yet and at each of these
villains seem to be made up from a
different natural element earth fire
water the idea that I'm gonna go with
right now is that these could actually
be based on the elementals the
elementals are more obscure characters
or from the Doctor Strange comics they
are ancient beings that wield power over
the natural elements hydron controls
water Magnum controls the earth Hellfire
controls fire and Zephyr controls air
perhaps the villains we're seeing so far
aren't Sandman multi man and hydro man
their figures based on Magnum Hellfire
and hydron lesser known characters that
would be easier for the movie to explain
and adapt to screen but if this were
true where would Zephyr be well look
again at the shots of Tower Bridge
lightning strikes it a few times and
it's odd because the bolts hit the lower
drawbridge
that's not how lightning works right
lightning is supposed to strike the
highest vertical point like a skyscraper
a really tall tree an unlucky bird maybe
one of the towers of Tower Bridge but
not the lower level it's as if the storm
is aiming for people on the bridge the
way I fear lighting storms will do the
mean so perhaps this attack is caused by
some figure based on the elementals
effort an air based villain to match the
other three and if you look closely at
that cloud or smoke whatever it is
there's almost a humanoid shape in there
maybe I'm just seeing things
all this said I think there is still an
even simpler explanation than the
elementals and I'll get to in a bit well
also in the section we hear happy Hogan
explained to Peter that he's all alone
now this is interesting because he's
implying that the other Avengers are
absent for whatever reason dead or in
another reality or maybe they're just
not in Europe but you have to imagine
that if things got too bad
Iron Man Rhodey one of the others would
come in to help so there must be some
major reason coming out of endgame that
Peters all on his own all dead also we
briefly see Peter wearing this new
badass all-black suit maybe it's some
kind of stealth suit notice how that eye
pieces work like goggles that he can
flip down over his eyes just like
jerking his head my guess is that Nick
Fury could have given him this option
maybe Fury was taking a note from his
old friend Carol Danvers about
discretion announcing your identity on
clothing help with the covert part of
your job good idea
tranq Dart drags her away and that's
where Captain Marvel has been for 20
years you could see Fury and Hill and
the SCV behind Peter there now this
scene appears to be set in that carnival
location in Prague you can see the
ferris wheel in the background that was
the one that we saw in league set photos
and videos parently Peter will face off
with Mysterio here and it could be a nod
to the carnival set and that spider-man
faces Mysterio in the comics and as
peter faces hydra man or the elemental
hydra or something else in the Grand
Canal of Venice who move on to the big
reveal of the trailer you don't want any
part of this
okay here we meet the villain of this
movie Mysterio played by Jake Gyllenhaal
in the comics Mysterio is Quinton Beck
though others have used the alias over
the years
he is a master illusionist known for his
fishbowl style helmet which we actually
see him wearing and briefly here as a
former Hollywood special-effects artists
Mysterio uses practical magic hypnosis
toxic gas literal smoke and mirrors to
trick people Yavin appears and
disappears with Green Smoke as he does
here now here's the deal with Mysterio
he's totally over the top
everything's part of the show and yeah
his costume is kind of goofy lose the
helmet the big cape smoke actually when
he first appears in the spider-man
comics he presents himself as a hero
taking down an evil spider-man who was
really just him posing as spider-man to
make Spidey look like a criminal and I
think that is actually mysterious secret
agenda here and what's really going on
with these multiple villains I think
they're all elaborate illusions false
flag attacks created and controlled by
Mysterio so that he can come in and save
the day get all the credit that's why I
think he appears without the helmet here
he wants face time in front of all the
cameras later where the kids describes
him as Iron Man and Thor rolled into one
that's exactly what he wants to look
like the popular Avengers in this
perhaps post Avengers world notice how
he arrives almost exactly like Thor did
an infinity war with that and the Cape
it's like he's doing an impression his
armor and gauntlets that fire beams like
Iron Man does look closely at those
beams they form these green geometric
shapes most as if he stole them from dr.
Strange's mystic spells and look even
closer they ignite from these little
green sparks as if they're produced from
practical pyrotechnics rather than real
magic so whether or not Mysterio is
gonna call these things hydro man molten
man and Sandman or he's gonna call them
elementals I just think they're all big
hoaxes earth wind water and fire great
music good for planet ears but to NEETs
and storybook ii the work of a hollywood
mind so yeah I think Mysterio has
syndrome syndrome let's move on to the
final clip who is that guy he's like
Iron Man and Thor rolled into one
he's no Spider Man what is it with you
and spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect
- sup dickwad okay after an awesome
instrumental cover of the 60 spider-man
theme song we see all the students
watching news footage of Mysterio's
rescue create show cure with flash
praising spider-man while dissing Peter
just like flash does in the comics now
the fact that this other kid mentions
Iron Man and Thor by name means that
those heroes exist in this timeline
Peter responds to the comment with a
doubtful side I like maybe he's making
this face because he doesn't really see
the heroism of mysterious actions or
maybe he felt that it was too soon to
bring up those guys maybe because they
just died but to me really the casual
tone here suggests that Iron Man and
Thor are not dead like no one seems sad
to think or talk about them so I'm
thinking now that however the Avengers
restore the timeline or circumvent the
snap it probably won't require Stark or
Thor to sacrifice their own lives but I
don't want to make that promise because
look it's still too early to know how
the timeline meddling will work in the
MCU going forward but here's what I will
say there are cats all over this trailer
maybe like Captain Marvel's cat all of
the cats in the MCU are actually Fleur
khun's you know dimension-hopping squid
monsters it look like cats but the ink
blowing up realities and then fixing
them so that we can have more
spider-man's let's check out one of my
recent Captain Marvel videos for
explanations of what if lurkin is but
here's my real question for you guys do
you think spider-man far from homes
timeline is the result of multiverse
hopping like we saw one into the spider
verse or time-travel butterfly effect in
events within the same timeline or could
all this be some conspiracy with
directors and heads of studios all lying
to us and far from home is actually a
prequel it's so what a lame thing to lie
about right comment down below with your
thoughts and follow new rock stars on
Twitter at you rock stars you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at EA vas
and subscribe to new rock stars were
in-depth breakdowns explanations in
theories of everything Marvel related
and yes I was in London recently but any
web-slinger's he saw were someone else
oh I got a run